hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outpro and no way Tabata
just did this the god of Black Clover
has appeared in the final battle is here
Judgment Day is upon us the final
villain truly has some unbelievable
Godly abilities including the ability to
bring overpowered characters who have
been dead for over a decade back to life
and these characters are fighting on the
side of the villains so this is gonna
get crazy Asta will have to go face to
face with a literal magic god in this
final battle so let's get into it you
guys know the drill if you enjoy our
black lower videos and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now it only takes you
a second but it helps me out with that
YouTube algorithm and if you're one of
the over 50 of people who watch our
videos but haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a big favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell Bell to turn
on all notifications subscribing on
YouTube is completely free but it is a
very real way of directly supporting the
channel right now finally this video
will contain Black Clover manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned the previous few chapters
wrapped up the Hino country Arc the true
power of tank and Sue were revealed and
we learned that this All-Seeing Eye has
many useful Powers but the price of
using it is giving up all of your magic
however as I mentioned in my previous
Black Clover video us that just happens
to conveniently not have any magic so
could that mean that he will become the
new user of tengenzu we'll have to wait
and see the paladins and the five-headed
dragon and Hino were defeated thanks to
some excellent teamwork by Asta the ruse
and seven and Ryu himself after he used
tengen suit to determine exactly where
and when the dragon should be attacked
after the battle we learned that both
Lucy and Julius now know how to
resurrect even the most powerful Mages
and literally bring them back from the
dead remember this for later because
some major resurrections are indeed
coming in other Shonen series one of the
biggest twists is which fan favorite
character is going to die and Black
Clover The Twist is which side character
that died in a flashback is gonna get
brought back to life by Tabata I mean
Lucius in the last few days before the
big Judgment Day that Lucius is planning
Asta decided to train as much as
possible with the reusen 7 in order to
get as strong as he can before the
imminent final showdown and as we leave
Asta behind in Hino country the latest
chapter starts off with a return to the
Clover Kingdom Lucius declares that
Judgment Day has finally arrived and he
and his paladins are about to take the
first step towards True World Peace
inside the Clover Kingdom capital all of
the most powerful Mages in the Kingdom
have done their best us to prepare for
the coming battle even the Clover
Kingdom's allies from other kingdoms
like little pachika and gaja from the
hard Kingdom and yuno's Mom and the
other Mages from the Spade kingdom are
standing by and preparing themselves for
what's to come apparently all the
citizens of the Clover Kingdom have been
evacuated to the noble realm in order to
provide them with the most protection
possible since that one smaller area the
noble realm is easier to fortify than
the entire Kingdom this in itself is an
indication that the Clover kingdom is
progressing and that the right people
are now in positions of power because I
feel like in the past the Nobles will
never have even allowed the commoners to
evacuate into their realm now the magic
Knights of the Clover Kingdom had tried
to locate Lucius before Judgment day but
they were unable to find him so their
only option was to fortify their
positions to organize themselves into
hardened battle formations and to await
the appearance of Lucius and his
paladins some of the strongest fighters
in the kingdom are now here and ready
all the magic Knight captains metal
owners with golion you know Yami and
many more Charlotte is also there of
course and in the tense moments before
the battle she has a brief but
meaningful conversation with Yami she
apologizes for avoiding him recently and
she vows to set aside her personal
feelings during the battle and to
fulfill her Duty as a magic Knight
Captain Yami tells Charlotte not to
worry because she'll always be his
comrade on the battlefield and he
clearly has no doubts about her
competency but just when you think that
Yami might still be completely ignorant
of the situation he indicates that he
might finally understand Charlotte's
feelings for him he says that after this
battle is over they should grab a drink
because there's something that he'd like
to talk to her about Charlotte agrees
that after they win the battle she will
hear him out now of course this could be
Ami wanting to talk about some random
thing like joint training between
Blackpool Bulls and the Black Rose but
I'm really hoping that he's actually
going to talk about moving their
relationship to the next level that way
they can finally hook up and then
Vanessa is mine anyway no more time for
vague romance because that is when
Lucius finally appears and not only does
Lucius appear but for some reason the
black Bulls Vice Captain knocked appears
to be with him jack definitely thinks
he's looking at knocked here but before
he can figure out what's really
happening Jack is severely injured by an
overpowered light magic attack light
magic you say why would knocked be using
light magic well because this isn't
knocked at all this is knocked brother
and yami's old BFF Morgan who has been
brought back to life by Lucius as one of
his Angelic paladins and in his Paladin
form Morrigan has the same horn designs
as Lucy fugus one of the highest ranked
Cliff off devils and the one who killed
mode again in the first place this is
likely an indication that Paladin Morgan
has formed some sort of contract with
lucifugus kind of like what happened
with sister Lily and Beelzebub Morgan
now almost certainly has access to
whatever lucifugus's magic attribute
happens to be just like sister Lily had
access to spatial magic but what's that
you say you think morrigan's
Resurrection is a big deal well I'm here
to tell you that he's not even the only
character who died in a flashback that
ends up coming back to life In This Very
chapter after Morris shows off his new
powers and abilities yet another
resurrected Paladin is revealed and this
time it is none other than the mother of
the Silva siblings the steel War
princess
asier Silva as nozel nebra and solid
look on in shock Aussie in her Paladin
form says I never would have expected to
be fighting you all like this and the
worst thing about it is that when she
says these words austier is actually
smiling lucius's Angels descend upon the
Clover Kingdom capital Lucius declares
that it is time to Grace this world with
happiness and that is how this chapter
ends wow this was some setup for the
final battle in the story it's one thing
for Lucius to be able to turn living
characters into paladins like he did
with sister Lily and it's another thing
for him to be able to resurrect somewhat
strong recently deceased people like
Heath Grice but the ability to resurrect
overpowered Mages who died over a decade
ago like Aussie is something else
entirely Lucius is far more powerful
than most people realize he is by far
the strongest characters we've ever seen
in this story he seems to have the power
of a literal God and he's only getting
stronger with all the pieces falling
into place for the final battle we just
need to see when and how exactly Asta is
going to show up since we haven't seen
the black Bulls on the battlefield yet
other than Captain Yami of course it is
likely that they are in the process of
retrieving our stuff from Hino country
as we speak we can expect Asta and the
black Bulls to make an epic entrance on
the battlefield sometime in the near
future it's been a long time coming and
this final showdown will definitely be
an absolutely incredible experience for
all of us as readers as we witness it
weekly what did you guys think about the
resurrections of Morrigan and asier does
this mean that even more characters
could be resurrected in the future like
for example asta's mom or even leaked
and the first wizard King Lucius really
is seemingly Unstoppable at this moment
but as the Hino country Arc taught us
the paladins themselves definitely can
be stopped so what happens when say
Morgan and asier are stopped I think
that just like with Lily their true
personalities will try to break through
lucius's Troll And so it's likely that
both of them will be subdued just like
sister Lily was but what happens to them
after that will they die after Lucius is
defeated since they were both dead
before or will they stay alive like we
can presume that sister Lily will seeing
knocked face to face with resurrected
Morgan and Noel face to face with the
mother that she barely even knew is
gonna be extremely interesting and
potentially extremely powerful what do
you guys say will the resurrected
paladins die in the end or will they
stay alive one thing's for sure Tabata
definitely wants us to see Lucius as
practically Unstoppable then we can bet
that defeating him is going to take a
lot out of all the Clover Kingdom
Warriors including our boy hasta I just
can't have wondering what major power-up
Asta is going to have to unlock in order
to win this fight will it be a tangency
plus anti-magic combo will it be some
sort of connection to asteroth the time
devil will Julius succeed in escaping
lucius's control long enough to help
Asta I do find it interesting that in
chapter 353 Ryu said to ask that both
Lucius and Julius now have the power to
resurrect Mages who are on the level of
grand magic Knight does him mentioning
Julius mean that maybe he could
resurrect someone else who could help
Austin the heroes like say asta's mom or
whoever asta's Dad is or maybe he can
initiate some sort of contract between
Asta and asteroth or maybe Asta will
finally awaken that black hole magic
that I've been theorizing about for
quite a while here on the channel don't
forget to leave your feedback down below
what will asta's ultimate power of be
and will it have anything to do with
Julius asteroth his mom or maybe even
his dad how will Asta ultimately defeat
someone as powerful as Lucius a villain
who is well on his way to becoming the
god of Black Clover if if you guys
enjoyed this video leave a quick like
and comment right now it means a lot and
if you're in that group of over 50 who
watch our videos but haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet please subscribe
right now and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on Twitter and Instagram
at anime Opera as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya Space Cowboys